y
[Música]
la comunidad internacional reacciona a
la crisis en kazajistán después de que
el presidente casi informar del azúcar
jeff reconociera que dio órdenes de
disparar a matar a los manifestantes que
originaron disturbios por la subida de
los precios del combustible naciones
unidades lo calificó de inaceptable
crece la presión internacional sobre
rusia para que en diálogo con eeuu y la
otan resuelvan las tensiones sobre
ucrania washington ve muy posible una
solución diplomática pero advierte que
no permitirá agresiones sobre quiere
el 2021 trajo consigo incrementos
históricos en los precios de bienes y
servicios como consecuencia de la
pandemia varios países de américa latina
ya han dado a conocer repuntes de hasta
el 8% en la inflación acumulada de la
bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
noticias en france o en 24 los acompaña
daniel hablando iniciamos con las
fuertes declaraciones del presidente de
kazajistán y casi más o marte tokáyev
quien reconoció haber ordenado disparar
a matar sin previo aviso a los
manifestantes durante las protestas en
la ciudad de almaty que dejan decenas de
muertos naciones unidas- calificó de
inaceptables los asesinatos tanto de
civiles como de uniformados el informe
desde andre a mayo
el presidente kazajo amenazó a los
manifestantes con la muerte el
mandatario ordenó al ejército disparar a
matar para hacer frente a los disturbios
en almaty y calificó de terroristas a
quienes protestan
qué tipo de negociaciones puede haber
con criminales con asesinos tuvimos que
lidiar con bandidos armados y entrenados
tanto locales como extranjeros eso es
bandidos y terroristas por eso hay que
destruirlos y eso se hará pronto
periodista el mandatario agradeció a
china de existan y turquía por su apoyo
mientras que rusia en 275 millones de
transporte militar con unidades del
contingente de paz de la organización
del tratado de seguridad colectiva
el grupo aéreo compuesto por más de 70
aviones y organizados por el ministerio
de defensa de rusia transporta durante
la última jornada a la parte rusa del
contingente de paz de la css a
kazajistán el portavoz agregó que los
militares rusos y la policía de
kazajistán retomaron el control del
aeropuerto de almaty
pero si algunas naciones han apoyado los
beligerantes declaraciones del
mandatario kazajo en europa el
presidente de francia por su parte
condenó la cacería de manifestantes y
dijo que seguiría monitoreando la
situación en la antigua nación soviética
desde el primero de enero se han
registrado fuertes protestas en
kazajistán luego de que el gobierno
dejara de controlar los precios del
combustible lo que duplicó el precio del
gas licuado de uso común entre la
mayoría de los vehículos en la nación
petrolera además hay un descontento
generalizado en el país que ha estado
bajo el control del mismo partido
político desde que se separó de la unión
soviética
y se acerca al día en que representantes
de estados unidos y rusia- discutirán
personalmente sobre la atención militar
en la frontera con ucrania previo al
encuentro previsto para el próximo 10 de
enero en ginebra la otan reconoció que
existe un riesgo de conflicto real pero
valoro los esfuerzos de diálogo el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón habló
por su parte en nombre de la comisión
europea para llamar a una conversación
franca y ordenada mientras que
washington advierte que no permitirá
agresiones sobre kiev
las acciones agresivas de rusia son una
amenaza para la paz y la seguridad en
europa estamos preparados para responder
con fuerza a una mayor agresión rusa
pero una solución diplomática sigue
siendo posible y preferible si rusia
elige
y en noticias deportivas de el tenista
serbio novak djokovic
agradeció el respaldo luego de haber
sido detenido por las autoridades
australianas tras ingresar al país al
parecer sin estar vacunado una situación
similar a la que afronta desde el 7 de
enero la tenista checa renata voracova
el caso del número uno del mundo ha
generado un incidente diplomático entre
australia y el país balcánico cuyas
autoridades califican el jugador como
víctima de un juego político más en el
siguiente informe
mensajes de simpatía desde los rincones
menos esperados el tenista serbio novak
djokovic ha recibido el apoyo de su
hinchada desde las calles de belgrado
hasta la habitación contigua en
melbourne donde se encuentra detenido
por negarse a presentar un certificado
de vacunación hace décadas lo siento
mucho por él porque no le deseó la
detención australiana a nadie australian
de esta sesión nobody' sanma out
sessions creo que un contexto político
de por medio así que realmente le deseo
suerte y le deseo libertad lo mismo para
nosotros
[Música]
el campeón del abierto de australia 2021
que desconoce si podrá defender su
título este año se tomó un tiempo para
agradecer en redes sociales
gracias a las personas de todo el mundo
por su apoyo continuo puedo sentirlo y
se los agradezco mucho australia que
registra 762 1504 contagios acumulados
de kobe 19 según el conteo de la
universidad johns hopkins exigen el tema
de vacunación completo para los
participantes del torneo o en su defecto
una exención médica como anunció haber
recibido el propio jugador semanas atrás
sin embargo las autoridades revocaron el
visado de djokovic por supuestas
irregularidades con la extensión
generando incomodidad entre serbia y
australia
misterio el señor djokovic no está
cautivo en australia no es libre de irse
en cualquier momento que lo desee la
fuerza fronteriza lo facilita
el exrector solo taiz este 7 de enero la
jugadora checa renata voracova fue
enviada al mismo hotel para migrantes
detenidos en melbourne luego de conocer
sobre la cancelación de su visa mientras
el serbio espera una decisión de la
justicia australiana sobre su
participación en el torneo recibió la
buena nueva de que será bienvenido en el
roland garros que se realizará en parís
en mayo y en noticias de eeuu a cadena
perpetua fueron condenados tres hombres
blancos involucrados en el asesinato del
afrodescendiente ahmad arber y en el
estado de georgia
el padre e hijo gregory y travis
mcmichael fueron hallados culpables de
perseguir y disparar con sus armas de
fuego a albert y de 25 años el 23 de
febrero de 2020 mientras frotaba por las
calles de una zona de mayoría blanca en
la localidad de braswell mientras que su
vecino william bryant en clavó las
acciones en vídeos y tendrá
posibilidades de acceder a libertad
condicional
en otras noticias de la unión americana
el desempleo cerró a 2001 2021 en 39 por
ciento este es un nivel más bajo desde
el inicio de la pandemia la tasa de
desocupación ha venido decreciendo desde
un pico del 14 7% en abril de 2020 la
más alta desde la gran depresión sin
embargo la creación de puestos de
trabajo fue de 199.000 en diciembre muy
por debajo de la expectativa los
empleadores de este país han estado
luchando por llenar millones de vacantes
en medio de la reticencia de los
trabajadores o por retornar a sus
puestos
y en otros temas económicos la inflación
en américa latina' no dio tregua en 2021
varios países ya han reportado el
comportamiento de los precios de la
canasta familiar con corte a diciembre
en uruguay hasta el mayor repunte con
cerca del 8% seguido de méxico que
registra un 7 por ciento el más alto en
20 años sólo ecuador estuvo por debajo
del 2% inflación es un problema
provocado por la pandemia como la
pandemia no se ha terminado las
presiones inflacionarias tampoco y esto
se hace presente en las disrupciones en
las cadenas de suministro volatilidad en
los precios de los commodities
particularmente de los energéticos y
escasez de productos y nos quedamos en
américa latina' víctor escobar de 60
años se convertirá este viernes en el
primer colombiano en morir por un
procedimiento de eutanasia sin puede ser
una enfermedad terminal este país
despenalizó la eutanasia en
1997 pero sólo para aquellos a quienes
se les diagnosticara en menos de seis
meses de restantes de vida la corte de
suprema d a mediados de 2021 cambió las
reglas y permitió que se aplique a
personas que padecen un intenso
sufrimiento físico o psicológico debido
a una enfermedad grave e incurable
aunque aún no estén cerca de la muerte
una decisión que rechazó la iglesia
católica por considerar lo como un
procedimiento como un homicidio por
ciento tiempo
claro que está por venir
estoy tranquilo
también dicho que
gente que va a seguir
una sensación lenta primero para que
tenga el tiempo de destino
y falleció a los 94 años el sidney
poitier primer actor afroamericano en
ganar el premio oscar a la mejor actor
por su papel en lirios del campo su
visibilidad lo convirtió en activista e
inspiración contra el racismo durante el
movimiento de derechos civiles nacido en
1927 en miami permanece como ejemplo a
seguir entre la comunidad artística
durante su vida rechazo papeles que
estereotipada en la etnia y decía
sentirse responsable de representar la
excelencia
con eso finalizamos este resumen
informativo quédense con nosotros
[Música]